[MUSIC PLAYING]
INDRANIL CHAKRABORTY:
Hello, everyone.
Good afternoon.
Hope you are all
enjoying the second day
at I/O. Thank you for attending
this session in person
and by live streaming.
I'm Indranil Chakraborty.
I'm a product guy at
Google Cloud Platform.
And we also have
Hanwook Kim, who's
a Product Manager at Android
Things for Enterprise.
In this session, we're going
to cover three key areas.
What are the key
products which Google
offers for IoT, particularly
as it comes to enterprise?
We're going to talk about
some of the key challenges
in building IoT
solution, and how Google
thinks about addressing those.
And finally, we'll have
some demos for you.
So let's get started.
Now, I think parking is a
problem which is near and dear
to everyone's heart.
All of us.
It is estimated that there
are around 800 million parking
spaces in United States.
San Francisco city alone has
half a million parking spaces,
but it's still really
hard to find parking.
Now, the SF city has
taken some initiative
in putting sensors in
many of the parking spaces
so you can detect whether a
parking lot is open or not.
And that data is sent to cloud.
So you can check on your
mobile phone which parking
lots around you are open.
That is great, because
now you don't have
to look around for parking.
But you can just find
parking automatically
on your mobile phone
and you park there.
Now, imagine if all the
parking spaces in US
is connected
through some sensor.
While each sensor might
be sending a small amount
of data on a periodic basis.
But cumulative, that is
a massive influx of data.
So the question is,
how do we handle
such a massive influx of data?
And how do you
build applications
which really scales?
We also have some
interesting partners
who have built interesting
applications for utilities.
We have a number of smart
meters in the US and in Europe.
And this number of our
partners and customers
have connected the smart meter
data from consumer homes.
And now, with Google
Cloud Platform
and with other
applications, they
can provide a pretty real-time
view of the energy usage
in different regions
for consumers.
Now, imagine, if all the
smart meters in all the houses
are connected, imagine
the influx of data.
There would be millions of smart
meters sending data every hour
or every 15 minutes.
That's a massive amount
of data to handle.
And what about security?
How do we get
real-time insights?
Those are all key
questions which
every developer has as they
think about building enterprise
applications.
Google has done some work
with data center optimization
as well.
As you know, we've
collected data from HVAC,
from coolers, from
chillers in data centers,
and we've used machine learning
to overall improve our power
utilization by more than 15%.
Now, imagine if every building--
commercial and
residential building--
can use the same concept
to actively optimize energy
consumption.
So there are some
key use cases I just
laid out in front of you.
And I think you all know
while phones were bigger
in terms of growth,
phones are bigger
than PC, significant growth is
expected for IoT in the coming
years.
Depending on the
analyst report you read,
it is estimated that around
20 to 50 billion devices
will be connected by 2020.
While each of these
devices might be sending
a small amount of bytes--
a small amount of data every
couple of seconds or minutes,
cumulatively, it's a
massive influx of data.
So that creates three
challenges as we think of
and what we hear from
partners and developers.
One is security.
How do you ensure that all
these devices are secure?
How do you ensure
that all those devices
have the latest operating system
and the right security patches?
And how do you ensure
that the data which
you're importing into cloud is
protected and secure as well?
Second is scale.
When you have millions of
billions of devices connected
to cloud or to the
internet, there's
going to be a massive
influx of data.
So how do you handle all this
data in a cost-effective way?
And also, make sure that you
can manage this massive amount
of devices, which are
globally dispersed,
in a way where you know
that all those devices have
the right firmware version,
has the right security patches
as well?
And finally, what do you
do with all this data?
Each of these devices
may have-- they're
sending massive amount of data.
How do you cost-effectively
store the data?
How do you analyze the
data so you can get really
actionable insight?
And how do you also do
it not just in the cloud,
but also on the edge?
So I'm going to
start with how we
think about these challenges
on the cloud side.
As you know, Google
has seven products
which are serving more than
a billion users currently.
And all these users
are highly-engaged.
So there's a massive amount
of data back and forth
between these products, as well
as our cloud infrastructure.
So as part of our
mission at Google
to organize world's information
and make it universally
accessible, we've been working
with data ingestion, storage,
and getting insight at a
massive scale over a decade.
In fact, we believe--
and in the process of
serving these billion
users, billion-plus users
for these consumer products,
we have built the world's
best compute infrastructure
across hardware, software,
networking, and operations
as well.
And we've built
our infrastructure
for developers in a
way where developers
think of these not as data
centers, but as one computers.
All these data
centers are connected
via our global network.
In fact, we are the
only non-ISP company
who has under-ocean fiber
connection between data
centers.
So as a developer, when you're
accessing Cloud Platform
and this compute infrastructure
in the data center,
it's not a collection of
different data center.
For you, it's just one computer.
You just write applications
and cloud takes
care of running them at scale.
In addition to our data
center infrastructure,
we've also been working hard in
building up our data management
and analytics stack as well.
We've built an open source
MapReduce, Dremel, Bigtable,
and many others over
the last decade.
And over the last
couple of years,
we've started to externalize
these internal tools
and this tech stack as services
on a Google Cloud Platform
for our enterprise customers,
developers, and partners.
So today, for example,
think about BigQuery.
BigQuery is our data warehousing
and analytics cloud service.
So when you run a SQL
query on BigQuery today
on Cloud Platform,
your query essentially
is running on Dremel,
which we at Google
internally use for
our applications.
When you upload some
data on Bigtable,
you're uploading on a
[INAUDIBLE] Bigtable service,
which has been used by Search--
which has been powering
Search, Ads, Gmail, and Google
Maps since 2006.
So everything that Google has
built and is in the process
of being externalized, including
TensorFlow and Spanner,
which you're already aware of.
So when it comes
to IoT, we believe
we have the industry-leading
data, analytics, and machine
learning services on
Cloud Platform, which
many of our developers
and enterprise partners
have been already using
to build applications.
And one thing they have asked
us many times is, this is great
that you have all
these services,
like Pub/Sub, BigQuery,
Dataflow, Bigtable.
But how do I connect
and manage my devices
and connect them
to cloud so that I
can start leveraging these
cloud services which you have?
So earlier this week, we
announced Cloud IoT Core,
with a goal to make it really
easy for developers to build
enterprise IoT applications.
So what is Cloud IoT Core?
Cloud IoT Core is a
fully-managed service.
It's 100% managed running
on Google Cloud Platform.
Let's talk about security.
As part of our Cloud
IoT Core, we've
built from ground up an
MQTT protocol endpoint
so that you can
bring your existing
device or your new device and
establish a secure connection
with Google Cloud
IoT Core over TLS.
And you can send and receive
telemetry over MQTT messaging
protocol.
We understand that a lot
of our enterprise customers
already have devices that
support standard MQTT protocol.
So we have built an
MQTT protocol bridge
so that you can connect your
existing or new device directly
to cloud and start leveraging
our data analytics services.
As part of Cloud IoT
core, whether you're
connecting one device
or millions of device,
the protocol bridge
scales internally.
You don't have to worry
about provisioning
a separate infrastructure
or provisioning a node.
You don't have to
worry about redundancy.
worry about sharding.
We scale internally.
So that makes it, for
a developer, really
easy to build application
without worrying about,
how do you scale from 10
devices to millions of devices
as you graduate from a prototype
to full-scale deployment?
And the protocol bridge also
underneath uses Cloud Pub/Sub,
the foundation of data routing.
Thanks to Cloud
Pub/Sub now, you can
access the data, which you have
from your diverse connection
of devices to Cloud IoT
Core from a center point
so you can view--
you can have a global
view of all your data
points across the
different devices.
We've also added some
key functionality
for device management.
With Cloud IoT Core now,
you can individually
configure and manage devices.
And I'll go more
into the details.
You can also now update and
control the remote devices
using Cloud IoT Core.
We have built a set
of APIs, which you
can use on your applications.
And we also have
a console, so you
can use that to manage
your device as well.
In addition, with
Cloud IoT Core,
you can provide
granular-level access
to a group of devices
using Cloud IAM.
So we're pretty excited
with this release.
We think this will really
help developers, you guys,
to start building using your
existing device or even new
devices running Android Things
or others to connect to cloud
and start leveraging our data
analytics and state-of-the-art
machine learning services.
Now, we understand that
developers and partners,
as you think about building
enterprise IoT applications,
you want to build some
quick prototypes to get
your feet wet, see if there's
an ROI, before you start
doing full-scale development.
So as part of our Cloud
IoT Core offering,
we also have a UI, which will
be available on Cloud Console.
Before I get into the
UI, let me tell you
about some of the key
concepts for Cloud IoT Core,
specifically as it pertains
to device management
and monitoring.
We have a notion
of device registry.
So if you are a
device manufacturer
and you have 10
categories of products,
you can create 10 registry.
And you can register
all those devices
for each of those
category under a registry.
And you can also assign
IAM policies and roles
to control access to users
on those specific registries.
So if I'm a device
manufacturer and I
want to make sure that
my users in my customer A
can only have view access, you
can do that with a registry.
And you can register
one device or millions
of devices in that registry.
So as you can see on the screen,
when you go to Cloud Console,
on the menu, there's a
section called IoT Core.
You click on that
and you will see
a list of different
device registries, which
you have already created.
You can also create a new
registry, give it a name,
select a region,
and assign a Pub/Sub
topic, which you want all
the devices to publish
their data to.
And once you select
on a device registry,
you will see a list of devices
which has been pre-registered.
And you can see whether
they're enabled or disabled.
So with Cloud IoT
Core, we also allow
you to disable a device
if you think a device has
become a rogue device.
Or for the testing
purposes, you want
to turn off a couple of devices
and just have one device on,
so you can start testing the
connection to the device.
For the purpose
of authentication,
security is pretty
close-- we are
very particular about security.
So we wanted to make
sure that as a developer,
you can individually
authenticate
a device or a group of devices.
So Cloud IoT Core has
support for public key-based
authentication.
So asymmetric keys
for authentication.
And the way it works is you can
register your device by adding
a public key to Cloud IoT Core.
And the device, when it wants
to connect to Cloud IoT Core,
it has to create a JSON web
token of the public key,
and then send it
to Cloud IoT Core.
That is the identity
of the device.
And we use that to
authenticate the device
and make sure that the
device, which is connecting,
is really a real,
registered device.
As part of our
launch, we have also
been working very hard with
a number of device partners.
So we are very excited that with
the launch of Cloud IoT Core,
we have announced partnership
with a couple of key leading
device manufacturers, such as
Intel, Microchip, NXP, Sierra
Wireless, Marvell,
and many others.
And we're working
closely with our partners
to make it easy for
developers to connect
partner devices to Cloud
IoT Core right off the gate.
For example, this is a really
tiny microcontroller, ESP8266.
And thanks to our
partner at Mongoose OS,
you can now connect a tiny MCU
like this to Google Cloud IoT
Core and start leveraging the
data and ML services on Cloud.
So we're very excited
about what we're building
and how we're working
with our partner ecosystem
to really help
developers so they can
build compelling application.
In addition to
hardware partners,
we're also working with
application partners as well.
So we've announced agreements
with a couple of application
partners, such as Mnubo,
Helium, and a bunch of others
which are coming along.
So we're very excited with the
announcement of Cloud IoT Core
and how we're building
partner ecosystem,
so that developers
can really start
building compelling enterprise
application using Google Cloud
Platform infrastructure.
I want to spend a
couple of minutes
on some of the other services,
which really adds value.
As we think about the
overall IoT platform, some
of these services
which are already
existing today in
Cloud, really helps
you to build compelling
applications.
One of them is
Google Cloud Pub/Sub.
What's great about Pub/Sub
is that for Cloud IoT Core,
it sends--
all the devices
which are registered
to a registry, the data
from all those devices
are published to a
Cloud Pub/Sub topic.
And what this
allows you to do is
you can collect data from all
those devices into one topic,
and then start analyzing it
using downstream services.
Pub/Sub has durable
message persistence.
What this means is you
can wait for seven days
to send a response
back, or you can even
send it within a minute.
It also allows you to access
data globally, as I mentioned.
And what's great about Pub/Sub
is that now the Cloud IoT Core
integrates easily with Pub/Sub.
It really separates the
application development
from your upstream
device firmware changes.
So you can constantly
update your application,
build new applications
without needing
to change your upstream format.
And Pub/Sub also allows you
to use powerful services
for building applications such
as Cloud Functions, Dataflow.
Or even, you can use your
existing ETL pipeline
or third-party services to
consume the data from all
those dispersed global
devices and start building
interesting applications.
Once you've ingested the data
in a secured way using Cloud IoT
Core, and once you have routed
the data using Google Cloud
Pub/Sub such that you
have a global access view,
you can then start using
our cloud data services
for analysis,
storage, and insights.
And this is where we want to
have humans and machines learn
from the data.
So you can use BigQuery,
which is our data warehousing
and analytics platform, to
analyze hundreds of billions
of rows of data in
a couple of seconds.
And then you can use
that data to train
a machine learning model.
So you can use Datalab to
analyze the data from BigQuery,
connect it to Cloud ML, train
machine learning models,
and then eventually
use those model
to predict either power failure,
demand usage, or maintenance,
and then send it
to Cloud IoT Core.
And then from there, you can
either send it some alerts
or you can even send it
upstream to the devices as well.
So this is how we think
about our overall platform,
and how we think about the
cloud portion and its connection
to devices.
So here you will see, you can
use an Android Things device,
which Hanwook is
going to go more
into the detail,
or any other device
with other embedded
operating system.
You can connect to Cloud IoT
Core using MQTT and a secured
connection to send your
measurement and other telemetry
data.
All that data gets [INAUDIBLE]
into Pub/Sub, on Cloud Pub/Sub,
from where you can then route
it to either Cloud Function
to build a simple rule
and then act on it.
You can do some complex event
processing using Dataflow.
And then you can use BigQuery
or Bigtable to store data cost
effectively, use it for
time series analysis
or for other ad hoc analysis.
Feed it to Cloud Machine
Learning, Cloud ML,
which is our managed service for
TensorFlow for training machine
learning models.
And then you can use the
same Cloud ML for prediction,
and then send the data
back through Cloud IoT
Core for any actions you
want to take on the devices.
So again, we're very excited
with the upcoming launch--
with the launch announcement
of Cloud IoT Core.
More is going to come.
We'll get more details.
But I want to hand
it to Hanwook,
who is going to cover Android
Things for Enterprise.
HANWOOK KIM: Thank you.
Hello, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
INDRANIL CHAKRABORTY: Thanks.
HANWOOK KIM: Hello, everyone.
So I'm going to talk about the
other side of an IoT solution,
which is devices,
devices in the field,
which is also known
as edge devices.
And they're devices that
are collecting information
about your operations.
In some cases, you know exactly
what data you're looking for.
And maybe you're
looking for something
that has high fidelity.
Something that
has more accuracy,
maybe more sampling rates.
Or maybe there's
a new sensor that
came out that you want to apply
to your enterprise solution.
Or maybe you're looking for
something, just a cheaper
option at the end of the day.
Or maybe you have a hypothesis
that you want to try and test
before you actually
deploy and figure out
whether you can actually
identify new signals to drive
better outcomes
for your operation.
Then, you need devices
to actually control
your operations.
And some of these
devices are actually
the same ones that are
actually collecting devices.
Some of them are not.
They may be single points.
They may be multiple points.
And they could be simple
things like relays to hundreds
of relays, or maybe even a
single device as [INAUDIBLE]
in terms of like a controller.
These devices are typically
powered by either MCU-class
devices--
simple things like measuring
temperature as an example--
to SOC-class devices,
which is a system
on chip, which is typically
much more powerful than an MCU
and much more flexible.
And those are the
types of devices
in which you want to have some
on-device intelligence or maybe
even complex operations.
And types of devices
may be things
like cameras, gateways, point
of sales machines, maybe even
sensor hubs.
And this last
class of categories
is where Android
Things is here to play.
We want to help our developers
build these devices,
to be able to
collect information
from your operations,
but also be
able to control your operations
much more easily and much
faster.
There's already been a bunch
of sessions on Android Things,
so I definitely encourage you
to look at the video streams.
So I will provide you
with a basic understanding
of Android Things in the
next couple of slides.
So Android Things
essentially is Android.
We've optimized it for IoT.
So essentially, we've
taken out the components
that aren't relevant for IoT.
So as an example, things
like user-facing applications
or maybe system
UI, notification.
And then we've added things
very specifically that
is needed for an IoT device.
So things like peripheral
I/O, user drivers,
so that you can add peripherals
and component to devices as you
need to.
And in the process, we
actually made Android Things
also smaller as IoT devices
have a smaller footprint.
For enterprise, I think the
importance of Android Things,
I think comes down
to three points.
One is scale.
So obviously, if you're
already a developer for Android
Enterprise, Android Things
uses the same Android APIs
and the same
developer tool kits,
like Android SDK
and Android Studio.
If you're not
familiar with Android,
obviously we've got
a vibrant ecosystem
that you can tap into,
so you can start actually
developing for devices
relatively quickly.
And Android OS is
obviously very--
it scales to-- now
we support over
2 billion devices across mobile
devices, tablets, TVs, watches,
and cars.
And of course, many
of these are actually
in enterprise
situations as well.
And now we're adding
IoT to that mix.
The second is security.
There was a session
earlier today
in the morning that actually
did a deep dive on security.
So again, if you're
interested in the security,
I'd encourage you
to watch that video.
So I'll give you a
high-level view of security
and how we think about
it from Android Things.
So we provide security
through OS hardening.
Security in the
OS and app update.
So I think this is a
very important piece
because we want to make sure
that the devices running
Android Things are
always patched up
to the latest version.
And you always have the
ability to actually update
your application that's running
device-side specific software.
We also support verified
boot, signed images,
hardware-backed keys,
and asset stations.
And we will continue to
provide and work on security,
because we know end-to-end
security from devices to cloud
is actually very important.
The last piece is, I kind
of mentioned it before,
which is peripheral
I/O and user drivers.
So this allows you
to basically connect
components, sensors, varying
different input devices--
displays into Android Things.
And allow you to actually
use those and actually
build applications and
devices across those things.
Android Things is currently
in developer preview.
We're in developer preview 4.
So we've done four releases.
We want to do releases
every six to eight weeks.
We encourage you to kind of
come along and play and check it
out.
We'll, again, do updates
every six to eight weeks.
And then, long-term support is
targeted for end of this year
and it will be based on O.
So that's the software layer
of Android Things.
The next layer that I'll
talk about is the hardware.
So we know that bringing
up hardware, new hardware,
is actually very
hard and complex.
So the approach we're actually
taking with our Silicon
partners is actually
going the path
of what's called a
SOM architecture,
the System On Module.
And a System On Module comes
with a couple of components.
It comes with a CPU, memory
storage, and connectivity.
Essentially, all the
pieces that you need to run
Android Things on.
So you pick a SOM.
It runs Android Things.
It's certified to
run Android Things.
And from there, you
go ahead and build out
what's called a
base board, which
has the additional components
that you want to include.
Things like I/O, display,
sensors, and so forth.
But because you've taken
a SOM that's certified,
Android Things actually works.
So there's no actually
additional certification
that you need to do.
So it helps you speed up your
development cycle relatively
rapidly.
And obviously, we're working
with a lot of Silicon partners
as we see.
And all these Silicon
partners are, obviously,
also very trusted in
the enterprise space.
So for enterprise,
what this means to
me is faster speed to market.
We've certified these SOMs.
They're proven to work
on Android Things.
You take these and you can
prototype relatively quickly
and actually iterate
on these designs.
Most of these
Silicon partners also
have developer kits as well
that are available to you.
And so in our demo
booth, which I believe
is A, which is one of the first
demo booths as you come in,
we basically got a dev
kit from Raspberry Pi.
We've got a couple of
components in a breadboard.
And we simply just wired it up.
And that is a device
that's actually connected.
and actually working.
And actually, it's
sending information back
to Cloud IoT Core.
There's another
version next to it,
which is the next iteration
of that, where we actually
printed out a PSB board.
We actually soldered
the components on.
So you can kind of
see the evolution
where you can go
quickly from prototyping
on the breadboard with wires
into something that's soldered.
And then when you're ready to go
into production, because again
it's the same SOM, you can
scale right into production.
And then, essentially
scale all these devices
throughout your enterprise to
realize the benefit of your IoT
solution.
The last layer that I'll
talk about on Android Things
is the services.
We want to make it easy for
you to use Google services.
We, obviously, believe
Google services
is going to help you drive
those insights that we
talked about on top
of your IT solutions.
Obviously, TensorFlow.
You can use TensorFlow
on Android Things
to run machine learning
locally on the device.
We also provide
local-based services.
And I also left a couple
of the consumer services
on there, like we
support the assistant.
We are working on supporting
[INAUDIBLE] as example.
So this is important because
in the cases of an enterprise
developer.
You may be actually developing
both for the consumers
and enterprise.
And we actually provide both.
This platform actually
supports both sides.
And obviously for enterprise, I
think the most obvious service
that makes a lot of sense
is actually Cloud IoT Core.
To be able to send data
from Android Things
to Cloud IoT Core, to be
able to apply data analytics,
machine learning.
And obviously then,
remote manage and control
those devices.
So in the case
where you may have
a sensor hub in a
manufacturing line,
or maybe even in a commercial
building HVAC system,
you want to be able to send
that information to the cloud,
analyze real-time usage,
predictive analysis, anomaly
detection.
And then to be able
to take your insights,
and then basically control
those devices back,
to be able to optimize your
yields or reduce energy.
So how do you connect
Android Things to cloud?
So we actually
have a code sample
that we actually created.
And this code sample is actually
an end-to-end code sample.
We've actually connected
a couple of sensors
to Android Things.
We've defined the
payload in terms of what
data information that we
want to collect and send
that information through the
MQTT bridge to Cloud IoT Core.
So we basically
show the full thing.
But at the end of
the day, it really
comes down to a
couple of core steps.
One is create your
Cloud IoT project
in which you need to define
a project ID, registry ID,
region ID.
You go to Android
Things and you want
to pull off that public key.
So sample code actually
creates a public-private key
in which you want to
pull out that public key.
And the private key
then is actually
stored within Android Key
Store, so it's secure.
The second step is then
you want to register
the device to Cloud IoT Core.
And I've already shown
you a command line method.
Obviously, this doesn't work.
This works really
well for prototyping.
But for when you want to go
into production, obviously
there's REST APIs
that we can use.
And we'll actually showcase a
demo for you about registration
and how important that
is in terms of onboarding
all these devices.
And the last step is to
configure a cloud service
on Android Things to start
sending the messages to cloud.
So relatively easy steps for you
to connect, use Android Things,
and connect to Cloud IoT Core
to use the power of cloud.
And again, the code sample is
on GitHub Android Things Sensor
Hub Cloud IoT.
So now, let's take
a real example--
or an example.
So let's say you're
building a camera.
Maybe this camera is a
quality control camera.
So you have your
specifications of what you want
to achieve in your product.
And you evaluate
the different SOMs
that we actually provide
based on price, performance.
You pick the one that
works best for you.
You build your product
around those things.
And it comes with
Android Things,
so you build your APK to
do the camera controls,
the video data, kind of capture
and processing and streaming,
and you connect it to cloud.
And what actually then
becomes more interesting
is the on-device intelligence
feed, that little yellow piece,
which is the TensorFlow piece.
In the case of quality control,
especially in the cases
of where they're abstract.
And maybe they're pattern-based,
so you can't actually
define rules or they're learned.
I can imagine a person at
the end of a line that's
looking at these
widgets, and they just
get smarter about
detecting like,
what's a defect
versus not defect?
Those are all the
same cases in which
you want to be able to
use machine learning.
So as an example,
maybe you're trying
to define a quality
of a wood grain.
There's no specific rules
about what good looks like.
But when you see a
particular wood grain,
you know what that
good looks like.
Or maybe it's a marbling
on a piece of beef.
As an example, you want to be
able to grade things from A, B,
to C. And that's subjective.
Or, maybe it's a pizza line.
And maybe it's hand tossed.
And you expect some
variation in a pizza.
You don't expect everything
to be in the right place.
But when you see this
pizza, you kind of know
what good looks like
versus bad looks like.
Those, again, good
examples of where
you want to be able to
use machine learning.
But you don't want to stream
all this information back
to the cloud because it's
actually a lot of information.
So this is, again,
where you want
to be able to use TensorFlow
on device with your models
to do decisions locally and
only stream the information back
to the cloud to enhance
your models in the cloud.
And as you make improvements
into the model in the cloud,
you actually send the
parameters back to the device
to update the model.
So you have this kind
of constant iteration
of increasing, of making the
models much better over time.
Then, you can use,
obviously, Android Things,
to make sure that the OS is
updated to the latest patch
using your latest application.
You can also use cloud
to do remote management.
So you can identify and alert
yourself if one of the cameras
is down.
Or maybe you're just
collecting quality information
and you want to be able to
compare across five lines
and see which ones are
actually doing better.
And this scales if
you have one camera
or if you have
hundreds of cameras.
Or, if maybe you want
to take one camera
and you actually want to
retrofit your whole line
with a whole bunch of sensors.
So you can kind of get a sense
of what the line is doing.
So you can start thinking
about correlations between,
what is the condition
of your line,
and what are you
defining as defects?
So maybe you can get
into predictive analysis
around forecasting
issues that come along.
And that's the beauty of
Cloud IoT and Android Things.
It scales as you start
thinking about the use cases.
And as you add more
use cases, you simply
add on more sensors
and more devices
and you stream
that to the cloud.
So to wrap it up,
we're trying to make
it easier for
developers and partners
to build enterprise IoT
solutions from edge to cloud.
Android Things really supports
building out the edge computing
for local controls, local
alerts and notifications, data
preprocessing, applied
analytics and machine learning.
This will allow you to
design a system that
will improve performance.
In the cases where you don't
want to actually send data
to the cloud and back, you can
make those decisions locally
on the device.
Or build for bandwidth
requirements.
So if you have restricted
bandwidth requirements,
you want to do some
processing on the device
and send only the
information you absolutely
need to the cloud.
And then lastly, be tolerant
of offline use cases,
whether they're either
intended or even non-intended.
Or you just need redundancy
where you want to, again,
make some local
decisions on the device,
but also make those same
decisions in the cloud as well.
So we're working on solving
some of these key challenges
through better managed
security, scalability insights.
And so we're really excited
about what you think of Android
Things with Cloud IoT Core.
So I encourage you to-- invite
you to test it out and give us
some feedback.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So now we're going
to go through a demo.
So the cameramen is going to
come up and switch on the video
so you guys can see from
the live stream, as well
as the ones in the back.
And on our demo
board, we actually
have three demos
I'll run you through.
And the demos I'm going to run
through is around registration.
So registration in
[INAUDIBLE] enterprise
is actually very challenging
because the scale
of registration
becomes very difficult.
It's no longer about just one
device, but it's about tens
and hundreds and
thousands of devices.
And how do you effectively
actually register these devices
to Cloud IoT to
stream information?
So talking to our
partners, we are
going to show you basically
two variations to show
what the possibilities are.
So we're going to focus on
the right set of devices.
And you can kind of
see from the screen,
there's actually a QR code.
And so we've actually built
a mobile app for the demo
to basically register.
What the app will
do essentially,
number one is I'm going
to sign in by myself--
as myself.
And it's going to check
whether I'm actually
authorized by Cloud IoT
to actually add devices
as an authorized user or not.
So that's the first step.
The next step is I'm going to
go and capture the QR code,
as an example.
So I'm going to go and
capture the QR code.
And this app is very simple.
So it's basically
got just two buttons.
So I've captured the QR code.
And the QR code
basically gave me
all the information I
need to now register
my device to Cloud IoT.
So I used the REST APIs
to now register the app.
I'm going to hit Add Device.
And then on the screen
Indranil is showing
is basically the
device register saying
we'll show the Device Manager.
And that device will now show
up on that Device Manager.
And then if you also
noticed in [INAUDIBLE],
you could see that the
device actually turned on.
And what the device did was
as soon as it could actually
talk to the cloud, it
actually lit up the LEDs.
And then we actually showed
the temperature of that device.
And now, that information is
actually streaming every second
to Cloud IoT Core.
So I'm going to go now--
I put that on my machine number
1, the location number 1.
So now I've got a second device.
I'm going to do the same thing.
Capture the QR code,
and then Add Device.
And then same thing.
You're going to see it
show up on Device Manager.
And then soon, you're going
to see the device light up.
As soon as it connects and
it's actually sending data.
Again, it's sending every
second and so forth.
So now I'm going to continue
to go down the line,
capture the QR code, Add Device.
Go to the next one.
Capture the QR code, Add Device.
I'm going to go and capture
the QR code, Add Device.
And the last one.
Again, maybe a
different location.
I'm going to capture the QR
code, and then Add Device.
So every time I did that,
you could see how quickly I
was able to get six
devices, see the visibility
on Device Manager.
And actually,
sending, again, data.
They're actually
connected to Cloud IoT.
Every second, I'm actually
sending temperature data back
to that.
So that's one example of how
you can actually register
a whole bunch of devices.
The second method is what's
called pre-provision.
So in those cases where
the public-private keys
are actually created
at the factory.
The public keys are actually
provided to the enterprise.
And the enterprise, we
actually set those devices up
in the back office.
So what Indranil will
show you is the Device
Manager will see
a set of devices
that are already registered,
but they're disabled.
Because these
devices are en route.
So what I have on my app--
I'm going to use
the app as well--
is I'm going to go and query
that device registry where
it has all the devices
in which we said,
these are preregistered.
Now, I'm going to go and
install these devices
in the place I want.
And maybe I'm not ready yet.
As soon as I'm ready--
maybe I'm doing a test.
Maybe I'm in pre-production.
I want to go in and
enable all these devices.
So I have an app.
Again, I'm going to
have two buttons.
One is Disable and one's Enable.
I'm going to hit
the Enable button.
And as soon as I
do that, you'll see
all the devices get enabled.
And then as they get connected,
they'll all light up.
So we'll go and do that.
So we'll bulk enable
devices right now.
So you can see that
some of the devices
are starting to light up.
And they're all
lit up right now.
So now, those are 12 Raspberry
Pis running on Android Things.
We also included the expressive
boards running Mongoose OS.
So again, they're a
partner of Cloud IoT.
And we did the same thing.
So it's the same process.
So this registry process
is the same across OSes.
We want to make
this really simple
for you to be able to get
register devices to Cloud IoT
and to actually manage
them in one place.
Then, now I'm going to
transition to the next demo
back to Indranil.
[APPLAUSE]
INDRANIL CHAKRABORTY:
Thank you, Hanwook.
So Hanwook showed
you a demo of how
you can do batch registration.
And you can even
disable and enable
a large chunk of devices,
which is manufactured.
What I'm going to
spend some time
is giving a demo on
how you access data
from all these global, the
deployment of your devices,
and how you can create
some simple rules
as well to take some action.
So we have a dashboard here.
What we have done is we have
taken these set of devices,
a number of those devices,
and we have deployed them
across the Google campus in
Mountain View, San Francisco,
and in some of the
other offices as well.
And all these Raspberry Pi
devices running Android Things
are connected to Cloud IoT Core.
And they're constantly
sending data
about temperature, humidity,
pressure, and other factors
as well.
And what I can show you is
these are all the location
of the devices.
You can monitor.
You can do real-time
monitoring of all these devices
in terms of the
temperature and pressure.
So the left chart shows
you the local temperature
for a whole bunch of devices,
the humidity, and pressure.
What we also have is
a more detailed view.
So I can click on a device
and I can see, real time,
what is the temperature
of that device?
Whether it's outside or inside.
Humidity, light, and pressure.
And also, you can
see this chart.
It's actually moving
in every second
as it collects data
from different sources
and starts seeing it.
So in the interest of time, I'm
going to move to another demo
where we're going
to show how we can--
I'm going to switch
to the split screen.
Awesome.
So we have-- let me come here.
We have a Raspberry Pi
running Android Things
on this device, which
is measuring temperature
and light.
We have an Intel Edison running
Android Things in a relay.
And what I'm going to do is I'm
going to put my finger here,
which increases the temperature
and also blocks the light.
And you would see
that the fan turns on.
What is happening here
is we have built--
the Raspberry Pi is sending
data to Cloud IoT Core.
Cloud IoT Core
publishes it to Pub/Sub.
And from there, we
have a cloud function
which uses a simple rule to
see if the temperature goes
above 90 Fahrenheit, then
it sends the command back
to Cloud IoT Core to turn on the
fan through that Intel Edison.
Now, what I can also do is I can
turn it off from my UI as well.
So all I have to
do is-- let's see.
Just say fan.
I also created a JSON on.
So it's fan on equal to false.
And I just send the command
and the fan is turned off.
So you can either use the
system to create rules,
either using Cloud Function or
Dataflow to act on the device,
send command.
Or you can do it
from UI as well.
So as a quick demo
of batch registration
and how you can use
connected devices,
send to cloud to act on it, and
then send commands and messages
back to devices as well.
Let's switch to the main
deck so we can wrap it up.
So we went through this.
So in the summary, what
you saw was we have Android
Things, which really takes
care of security at the edge,
managing those devices
at scale at the edge.
And also, running
actionable insights
at the edge using TensorFlow.
And we have Cloud
IoT Core to connect
your existing and new devices
running Android Things--
security Cloud IoT, Cloud--
and then leverage our other
services such as Pub/Sub, Cloud
Function, Dataflow, and others
to have secured connection
from device to cloud,
run scalable app,
build scalable application, and
really get actionable insights.
So next steps, we
have helpful links.
So if you were interested
more in Android Things,
go to
developer.android.com/things.
Cloud IoT Core is
currently on private beta,
so you can go to
cloud.google.com/iot-core
and request access.
And we're reviewing access and
we'll provide you access over
the next couple of weeks.
So in summary, we're
very excited with what
you guys can do.
And we love to hear
your feedback, both
on Android Things
and Cloud IoT Core
as it comes to building
enterprise applications.
Thank you.
HANWOOK KIM: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]